.
I MEAN, WHAT'S GETTING RELEASED
TO THE PUBLIC?
>> THIS IS A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT,
AFTER YEARS OF NOT SEEING
DONALD TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
THERE IS A CLEAR SIGN, A
MOVEMENT BY CONGRESS TO
POTENTIALLY RELEASE DONALD
TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS OR A
SUMMARY OF THOSE RETURNS TO THE
PUBLIC.
WHAT JUST HAPPENED WAS A VOTE
ALONG STRAIGHT PARTY LINES.
REPUBLICANS ALL VOTING AGAINST
A MOTION TO SUBMIT THIS REPORT
FOR THE RECORD.
DEMOCRATS ALL VOTING IN FAVOR
OF IT.
DEMOCRATS STILL IN THE MAJORITY
FOR ANOTHER COUPLE OF WEEKS,
GOING DOWN ALONG PARTY LINES,
24 TO 16 WAS THE VOTE.
THEY SUBMITTED THE REPORT TO
THE HOUSE ON TRUMP'S TAX
INFORMATION.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT MEAN?
IT'S STILL UNCLEAR AT THIS
MOMENT.
IT COULD BE, AS YOU SAID, A
SUMMARY OF THOSE YEARS OF TAX
RETURNS, THOSE SIX YEARS,
PERSONAL TAX RETURNS, BUSINESS
TAX RETURNS.
WHAT THE COMMITTEE HAS FOUND,
PERHAPS, WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT DETAIL ABOUT ALL OF
THAT, PERHAPS IT WILL BE MORE
OF A TOP LINE INFORMATION,
WHERE PERHAPS IT COULD INCLUDE
SOME OF THOSE RAW MATERIALS,
SOME OF THE ACTUAL RETURNS
THEMSELVES.
WILL THAT BE PART OF THE RECORD?
THOSE ARE STILL QUESTIONS WE
WILL HAVE TO SORT OUT WHEN WE
DO TALK TO THESE MEMBERS AS
THEY LEAVE THIS MEETING.
THEY'VE BEEN BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS FOR HOURS, TRYING TO
DECIDE HOW TO MOVE FORWARD.
REPUBLICANS FURIOUSLY BATTLING
ANY EFFORTS TO RELEASE THESE
TAX RETURNS.
DEMOCRATS INSISTING THAT THEY
MUST BE HELD PUBLIC.
THEY HAD PUSHED RELEASES
SUGGESTING THERE NEEDED TO BE
CHANGES TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS FOR HOW PRESIDENTIAL
TAX RETURNS ARE DEALT WITH
HERE.
THAT PART OF THE PROPOSAL AS
WELL STILL REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
THIS VOTE, ESSENTIALLY, ALLOWS
THEM TO MOVE FORWARD IN
PUBLICLY RELEASING DONALD
TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS, SOME OF
THAT FINANCIAL PRIVATE
INFORMATION SOUNDS LIKE IT WILL
BE REDACTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
WE SHOULD CERTAINLY LEARN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT MORE ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S PERSONAL
FINANCIAL SITUATION, HIS
BUSINESS FINANCIAL SITUATION,
OTHER COMPANIES HE HAS BEEN
INVOLVED WITH, ASSUMING THIS
BECOMES PUBLIC, AND STILL
REMAINS UNCLEAR, ERIN, WHEN
THIS WILL BECOME PUBLIC.
IT COULD BE SOON, IT COULD TAKE
DAYS.
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE MANY DAYS
LEFT IN POWER, AND MOVING HERE
IN THE FINAL DAYS TO RELEASE
DONALD TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS,
WHICH IS KEPT FROM THE PUBLIC
FOR MANY YEARS.
>> I KNOW FROM TALKING TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
CONGRESSMAN LLOYD DOG IT HAS
BEEN CLEAR, RIGHT, THAT THEY'D
BEEN PUSHED INTO THIS,
ESSENTIALLY, RIGHT, IN A
PROFITABLE DAY WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN THEM AND GONE THROUGH
THEM AND BEEN ABLE TO EVALUATE,
AS THEY SAID, WHETHER HIS
BUSINESS AND FINANCIAL DEALINGS
HAD ANY IMPACT ON HIS ACTIONS
AS PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE THIS IS HAPPENING DAYS
BEFORE THEY LOSE POWER, THEY
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO THROUGH
IT ALL, BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
TIME TO GO THROUGH IT ALL, THEY
WERE PUT IN THIS POSITION OF
PUTTING IT OUT PUBLICLY.
CAN I ASK, MANU, IT SEEMS, TO
ME, UNUSUAL, AND I KNOW WE'VE
NEVER BEEN IN A SITUATION LIKE
THIS WITH PRESIDENTIAL TAX
RETURNS, BUT I MEAN, IN TERMS
OF A COMMITTEE VOTE, THAT IT IS
UNCLEAR, STILL, AT THIS MOMENT,
EXACTLY WHAT THEY VOTED FOR?
WHETHER IT IS A SUMMARY, YET TO
BE WRITTEN OR HOW TO BE PUT
TOGETHER, WE DON'T KNOW, OR
WHETHER IT IS, IN FACT, ALL THE
TAX RETURNS AS WELL AS THE,
FRANKLY, IT WOULD BE THOUSANDS
OF PAGES OF BACKUP INFORMATION
THAT GOES WITH THAT?
BACKUP
INF>> THE SECTION OF THE TAX LW
THAT GOVERNS THE RELEASE OF
THIS INFORMATION, WHICH RICHARD
NEIL, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE, USED TO OBTAIN THE
TAX RETURNS, IS VERY --
IT HAS STRICT RULES ON SECRECY,
WHICH IS WHY THEY HAVE BEEN
VERY CAGEY ABOUT EXPLAINING
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE THE
RETURNS.
THEY REFUSED TO CONFIRM FOR
SOMETIME THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAD
THE RETURNS, EVEN THOUGH THEY
WE HAVE REPORTED THEY HAD THE
RETURNS, AND THE AFTERMATH OF
THE COURT VICTORY, THE
DEMOCRATS WON, AND THEY TURNED
OVER THOSE RETURNS TO THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT.
TREASURY DEPARTMENT IS SENT
THOSE RETURNS TO CAPITOL HILL.
ALL THAT HAS BEEN A VERY
SECRETIVE PROCESS.
THAT'S WHY THIS HAS BEEN BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS FOR ALL DAY, ALL
AFTERNOON.
WHY WE DON'T REALLY KNOW MUCH
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THEY PLAN TO
RELEASE IN PUBLIC, BUT TAKING
AN AFFIRMATIVE STEP TO RELEASE
THEM PUBLICLY, THAT IS THE VOTE
WE JUST SAW.
WE SHOULD HOPEFULLY LEARN IN A
MATTER OF HOURS, IF NOT SOONER,
WHAT EXACTLY THEY PLAN TO
RELEASE.
>> MANU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOPEFULLY, WE'LL GET MORE
INFORMATION IN A MOMENT.
I MENTIONED CONGRESSMAN LLOYD
DOGGETT, AND HE'S GOING TO BE
WITH ME IN A MOMENT.
WHO IS IN THOSE MEETINGS FOR
THE ENTIRE AFTERNOON.
HE VOTED, MAKING HIS WAY TO THE
CAMERA NOW.
IN THE MEANTIME, RYAN GOODMAN
IS WITH ME NOW, OF COURSE,
CO-EDITOR AND CHIEF OF JUSTICE
SECURITY, FORMER SPECIAL
COUNSEL WITH THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT, AND MARTY SHIELDS,
FORMER SUPERVISORY SPECIAL
AGENT FOR IRS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
THANKS VERY MUCH TO BOTH OF
YOU.
MARTY, CAN I ASK, YOU AND YOUR
CAPACITY ESPECIALLY AGENT FOR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS, HOW
SIGNIFICANT IS IT THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO SEE ALL OF, OR SOME
SORT OF EXECUTIVE SUMMARY OF,
AND I'M HOPEFULLY GOING TO GET
MORE INFORMATION FOR US ON THAT
IN A MOMENT, THAT WE ARE GOING
TO SEE THIS FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, FOR THOSE YEARS,
2015 THROUGH 2020?
S FOR 2015
>> I THINK, ERIN, FIRST OF ALL,
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON, I
THINK IT'S A STUNNING
DEVELOPMENT, AND I AM SO
PLEASED CONGRESS IS BEING SO
CAREFUL IN MAINTAINING
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MR. TRUMP'S
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
IRS TAKES NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
TO MAINTAIN THE CONFIDENTIALITY
OF TAX RETURNS AND THEY'VE DONE
A FANTASTIC JOB OVER THE YEARS
OF DOING THAT.
I THINK EVERYBODY CAN TAKE
PRIDE IN THAT.
LET'S FACE IT, MR. TRUMP HAS
BEEN A FINANCIAL WIZARD, OR AT
LEAST SO HE CLAIMS.
LET'S SEE IF THOSE TAX RETURNS
REFLECT HIS BUSINESS WIZARDRY.
I SUSPECT YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
MASSIVE LOSSES ON HIS CORPORATE
RETURNS WHICH WILL THEN, SOME
OF WHICH, WILL BE CARRIED OVER
TO HIS PERSONAL RETURNS.
THE QUESTION RAISED, HOW CAN
SOMEONE WHO IS REPORTING
MASSIVE MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
BUSINESS LOSSES YEAR ON YEAR
MAINTAINS A LUXURIOUS LIFESTYLE,
LIKE MR. TRUMP, AND PAY NO
TAXES?
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE
HE'S PAYING NEXT TO NOTHING,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I DON'T WANT TO
POINT A FINGER AT HIM UNTIL WE
SEE JUST HOW HE HANDLED HIS TAX
RETURNS, OR HOW HIS ACCOUNTANT
HANDLED THOSE TAX RETURNS.
WHEN LOOKING AT THE TAX RETURNS,
WE WANT TO FRAME A REFERENCE.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE BOOKS AND
RECORDS THAT SUPPORTS THE TAX
RETURN.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS THAT WERE SUBMITTED
TO BANKS FOR LOAN APPLICATIONS
AND OUR ASSETS AND LIABILITIES
ON THOSE STATEMENTS COMMEND TO
IT WHAT IS ON THESE TAX
RETURNS.
>> SO --
YEAH.
SO, RYAN, DO YOU THINK, WHEN WE
LOOK AT THESE, KNOWING, AND
LET'S BE CLEAR, TRUMP HAS GREAT
ACCOUNTANTS, OKAY?
AND THINGS ARE DONE --
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE, MY GOSH,
LOOK AT THIS INVESTMENT, BLANK,
IT WON'T BE THAT SIMPLE, MOST
LIKELY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT IN
TERMS OF CONFLICTS OF INTEREST?
MARTY IS RAISING A POINT,
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF LOSSES.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT TONS AND
TONS OF LOSSES, LIFESTYLE THAT
CONTINUES, YOUR PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHAT DOES
THAT OPEN THE DOOR TO?
>> IT'S THE QUESTION YOU POSED
TO MANU ABOUT WHY THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC GENERALLY WANTS TO KNOW
BUT THEIR CANDIDATES FOR
PRESIDENT, THEIR FINANCIAL
SITUATIONS, AND THEIR TAX
RETURNS, TO SEE IF THEY MIGHT
BE CONFLICTS OF INTEREST THAT
COULD HAVE INFLUENCED THE WAY
IN WHICH THEY GOVERNED.
IN FACT, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WILL BE KEY HERE IS THERE IS A
FEDERAL CRIME FOR DENIAL OF
HONEST SERVICES, IF AT A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL TOOK OFFICIAL ACTS IN
EXCHANGE FOR PERSONAL BENEFIT.
A PERSONAL BENEFITS MIGHT BE,
IS HE LEVERAGED OUT TO FOREIGN
LENDERS?
DOES HE GET BETTER AT LENDING
ALONE AGREEMENTS WITH THESE
FOREIGN LENDERS OVERTIME WHILE
HE MIGHT BE TAKING ACTIONS THAT
COULD INFLUENCE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THOSE FOREIGN
LENDERS?
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC ALWAYS WANT TO
KNOW FROM A PRESIDENT, NOW THE
TAX RETURNS WILL POTENTIALLY
REVEAL THAT KIND OF
EMBARRASSING INFORMATION, IF
NOT ILLEGAL.
>> MARTY AND RYAN, STAY WITH
ME.
I HOPE MANU IS STILL WITH US AS
WELL.
I WANT TO GO NOW FOR HIS FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE THIS
COMMITTEE'S MEETING ABOUT TODAY
TWO DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
LLOYD DOGGETT.
CONGRESSMAN, I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS.
HERE WE ARE, YOU'VE SPENT HOURS
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, YOU JUST
COME OUT FROM THE VOTE.
CAN YOU FIRST EXPLAIN TO ME
EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE ALL VOTING
TO DO?
ARE WE GOING TO SEE A SUMMARY
OF SOME SORT, OR ARE WE GOING
TO SEE ALL OF THE TAX RETURNS?
>> BOTH, BUT FOR A LIMITED
PERIOD.
YES, ERIN, WE'VE BEEN AT IT FOR
ABOUT THE LAST THREE AND A HALF
HOURS, DISCUSSING ALL ASPECTS
OF THIS.
NOW THERE WILL BE A REPORT TO
THE HOUSE PREPARED BY CHAIRMAN
NEILL AND HIS STAFF, A VERY
THOROUGH REPORT.
IT INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
ATTACHMENTS.
IT INCLUDES ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS
FROM THE JOINT TAX COMMITTEE,
AND IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE SOME
TRUMP TAX RETURNS.
>> AND IS --
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GET, SORT
OF, ONE THING?
AN EXECUTIVE SUMMARY,
ATTACHMENTS, AND SOME OF THE
TAX RETURNS.
THAT IS GOING TO BE, AND WE'RE
NOT ALSO GOING TO GET ALL THE
TAX RETURNS, JUST TO BE CLEAR
HERE?
>> YOU WILL GET ALL OF THE TAX
RETURNS THAT THE SUPREME COURT
AND THE LOWER COURTS SAID
MISTER NEILL'S REQUEST COULD
GET.
YOU WILL GET ALL OF THOSE.
THAT MAY BE DELAYED FOR A FEW
DAYS, ONLY TO PERMIT TIME TO
REDACT THINGS, LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS, PERSONAL I.D.
NUMBERS, THAT TYPE OF THING.
YOU WILL GET THE COMPLETE TRUMP
TAX RETURNS, SUCH AS THEY ARE,
FOR THE YEARS THAT MR. NEIL
REQUESTED.
>> OKAY, SO --
2015 THROUGH 2020, TO BE CLEAR,
YEAH?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> I THINK WHAT I FIND
SURPRISING, OUR FOCUS HAD BEEN
ON THE IRS AUDIT, AND WHETHER
IT WAS BEING DONE PROPERLY.
THE IRS DID NO AUDITS AT ALL
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS THE DAY THEY
RECEIVED MISTER NEILL'S REQUEST
FOR THESE DOCUMENTS, AND THAT
TODAY, THE REQUEST OF THE FIRST
AUDIT THEY HAVE YET TO COMPLETE
A SINGLE AUDIT OF MR. TRUMP.
I THINK THEY WILL ALSO BE
SURPRISED BY WHAT IS NOT THERE
WITH THE TAX RETURNS, AND THAT
IS SUPPORTING DATA.
ANY TAXPAYER WHO GOES IN FOR
AUDIT HAS TO PRODUCE SOME
RECEIPTS, SOME AFFIDAVITS, SOME
SUBSTANTIATION.
THAT SEEMS TO BE MISSING FROM
WHAT WE'VE BEEN PROVIDED.
>> SO, IN THAT CONTEXT, TO BE
CLEAR, YOUR UNDERSTANDING, YOU
ARE SAYING THEY DIDN'T BEGIN
THE AUDIT UNTIL THE REQUEST
CAME IN, THEN THEY --
>> THE SAME DAY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING, I DON'T WANT TO JUMP TO
A CONCLUSIONS, I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M RIGHT, THAT THEY THEN
REQUESTED, THEY HAD QUESTIONS
ABOUT VARIOUS THINGS, AND
REACHED OUT TO TRUMP TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS, AND TRUMP DID
NOT RESPOND WITH THE BACK
UPDATED TO MAKE HIS CASE FOR
WHAT HE DID WHAT HE DID?
S CA>> I THINK YOU WILL SEE TENF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THESE
RETURNS THAT WERE CLAIMED
WITHOUT ADEQUATE SUBSTANTIATION.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE IRS
MADE AN EFFORT TO GET THAT
SUBSTANTIATION.
I INVITE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
REPORTS.
I THINK YOU WILL BE SURPRISED
BY HOW LITTLE THERE IS, AND I
HAVE MY DOUBTS ANOTHER TAXPA